like the Madonna of the cosmos but at
least to Madonna's but I think there's
way more than to thomases whether he's
the Cher alright here you go
hi I imagine asteroid passing between
the Earth and the moon could we see the
asteroid transit the moon but would it
be too small to see how rare would that
event be thanks I really like your show
and sorry if my english isn't correct
well that was better than anything ever
came out of your mouth kid you know I
know I don't
yes you're absolutely right though but
so if we were to see it an asteroid
transit the earth first of all the
transit the transit the moon yeah how
often does that happen it happens every
year
oh we do see this we're not let me be
specific there are enough small
asteroids out there by the way if you
count up how many big asteroids there
are versus how many small asteroids
there were there more small ones than
big ones okay all right when they get
really small we don't know they're
around until it's kind of too late
because they're not reflecting much
light because they're little so often
the asteroids that come between Earth
and the moon are discovered a few days
before it happens at most a week and so
this this happens several times a year
okay and now will it come exactly
between our line of sight to the moon
that's rarer that's a hard it's--that's
if it is with no one's caught it doing
that and so but it's great he asked that
because we recently had a Venus transit
and it's got people thinking right when
you're science literate you connect one
fact or thought to another and it
spreads out your knowledge and
appreciation of the cosmos so I applaud
the extension of the Venus transit to a
moon transit so you get these by the way
these are house sized asteroids right
and if they hit they could explode in
the air and level a thousand square
kilometers of Earth's surface
Wow okay that's comforting good to know
yeah and so unfortunately unfortunately
if one of those do does hit it won't
render us extinct but it would really
bad it'd be really bad for the people
who live
the impact point awesome yeah okay